Traveling by plane?
Here are some tips to help you get through airport security like a pro.
When you're packing your carry-on bag make sure that all liquids,...
...aerosols and gels like shampoo, toothpaste and creams...
...as well as foods like peanut butter are in travel-sized containers...
...that are 100 milliliters or less.
Together, all these containers should fit into one liter clear plastic resealable bag.
If you are a nursing mother or traveling with children under the age of two,...
...you can bring milk, formula, juice and baby food,...
...just make sure you pack so items are accessible to show the screening officers.
Medications and prescription drugs can stay in the same containers they came in.
Just make sure they are packed so they can be easily removed for inspection.
Laptop computers, video and film cameras...
...should also be packed so they can be easily removed.
If you're not sure what you can bring with you,...
...visit the CATSA website at www.catsa.gc.ca